okay let's have a conversation about a
possible treatment for some coronavirus
patients I really want to do this
carefully because unfortunately thanks
to Donald Trump
this is being propagandized incorrectly
by both sides people on both sides of
the political spectrum and the truth is
that almost no one is telling the truth
the full truth about this treatment now
if you've been watching this show last
week the week before I've been telling
you about many possible treatments for
corona virus for a while now one of
those that I told you about already is
chloroquine possibly combined with the
antibiotic zithromax azithromycin now I
know you're probably saying an
antibiotic to treat a virus we'll get to
that
okay let's table that for a moment
Donald Trump caught wind of this and
remember that this is just one possible
treatment and he has been propagandizing
around it from tweeted over the weekend
hydroxychloroquine and as a throme Ison
taken together I have a real chance to
be one of the biggest game changers in
the history of medicine very hyperbolic
the FDA has moved mountains hopefully
they will both hydroxychloroquine works
better with as a throme Ison according
to a journal be put in use immediately
people they're dying move fast god bless
everyone Trump also got into an argument
with a reporter about it after
mentioning it during a press conference
take a look drug called chloroquine and
some people would add to it hydroxy
hydroxychloroquine so chloroquine or
hydroxychloroquine now this is a common
malaria drug it's also a drug used for
strong arthritis somebody has pretty
serious arthritis also uses this in a
somewhat different form but
it is known as a malaria drug and it's
been around for a long time
and it's very powerful and then arguing
with the reporter about it about the
possible therapies yesterday mr.
president you said that they were for
immediate delivery of media we heard
over loitering yes we have millions of
units ordered bear is one of the
companies as you know big company very
big very great company millions of units
are ordered and we're going to see what
happens we're going to be talking to the
governor's about it and the FDA is
working on it right now the advantage is
that it has been prescribed for a
totally different problem but it has
been described for many years and
everybody knows the levels of the
negatives and the positives but I will
say that I am a man that comes from a
very positive school when it comes to in
particular one of these drugs and we'll
see how it works out Peter I'm not
counting on saying it will but I think
that people may be surprised by the way
that would be a game-changer but we're
going to know very soon but but we have
ordered millions of units it's being
ordered but from Bayer and there is
another couple of companies also that
that do it dr. patchy said there is no
magic drug for coronavirus right now
which you would agree I guess on this
issue let me know I think we only
disagree Lily sorry I fish agree maybe
and maybe not maybe there is maybe there
isn't we have to see we're going to know
is it possible is it possible that your
impulse to put a positive spin on things
maybe giving Americans a false sense no
I don't think shows any parents right
now more I don't think so I think that i
think it's got now but not get a frog on
a sister lovely course look it may work
and it may not work and i agree with the
doctor what he said may work may not
work i feel good about it still it is
just a feeling like you know so the
problem is that when Trump jumps in like
this almost nobody gets it right that's
the unfortunate reality you've got a ton
of Trumpets who believe this is the cure
this is a game-changer this is it that's
not what the sign says right now but I
also got a lot of messages on Twitter
from anti-trump ists and I'm an
anti-trump Asst
have been tweeting me David this is a
total sham there's no promise whatsoever
in this as a treatment and Trump is just
straight-up lying
so let's talk about the truth this is
one course of treatment that's being
tested so far it's been small-scale
tests I'll tell you about the larger
test that's starting there is enough
promise with this treatment that we need
larger testing to be done Trump said the
drug is approved to treat coronavirus
it's not it is an FDA approved drug for
malaria using it on coronavirus would be
an off-label use it would be speculative
it's not approved for coronavirus
treatment but maybe it could be used
under compassionate use or in trials
possibly okay there's a French doctor
DDA Rao who did a small non randomized
trial with it but we need to understand
the study that was done the study showed
excellent results it was a very small
sample size it was not randomized and it
was not blinded now why does this matter
this is really important if you're a
doctor and say you have 40 patients with
coronavirus you know the patient's ages
you know the patient's underlying
medical conditions so you as the doctor
could choose to try the new treatment in
this case chloroquine and azithromycin
you could say I'm going to give this to
the patients that are likely to do
better anyway the patients with fewer
symptoms the patient's more likely to
recover naturally anyway and you could
do this consciously if you want to skew
the results you could also do it
subconsciously
this is why the tests need to be
randomized and blinded the patients that
get the new treatment that's being
tested versus the standard treatment or
no treatment or a placebo they should be
selected randomly and the doctor should
not know which patients are getting
which treatment in an ideal world it
would be double-blind where the patients
also don't know if they are getting the
standard or the the potential new
treatment that wasn't done it wasn't
done with the chloroquine only treatment
it wasn't done with the chloroquine plus
as a thorough Meissen treatment so that
that's why we can't judge much from the
study we have so far
number two why an aunt
biotic for a virus important to
understand the azithromycin is not being
used to kill bacteria it's being used
because it's known to have an antiviral
like effect on lung cells in COPD
patients COPD of course a respiratory
illness so that's why the azithromycin
is being used so is this enough to be
promising absolutely along with many
other ideas is Trump over selling it of
course of course
is Trump totally wrong about this as a
likely cure yes it's way too early to
say that the reason that it's
dangerously irresponsible for Trump to
talk about this as a game changer is
that there are people especially
right-wingers who are looking for any
reason to stop self-isolation or not to
start it when Trump says hey this really
looks like it could be a game changer
you are probably pushing people towards
not behaving responsibly and that's why
Trump shouldn't do it it has potential
needs to be taxed tested extensively and
that's all we can say right now let's
next talk about the major trial that is
starting check this out the first 500
people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple productivity how to
accomplish more with less and got a
bunch of great personal productivity
tips out of it we should allow ourselves
a little time every week to either get
creative keep your brain sharp learn
something new it's great for mental
health and almost all the classes are
under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with skill share you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of
for people with experience so you can
just get better at something you're
already good at and again the first 500
people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
completely free premium membership for
two whole months giving you access to
every class Skillshare offers check it
out I put the link right underneath this
video